the season for giving which for
retailers and shipping companies means
it's the season for delivering and all
those millions of tons of cardboard
boxes will eventually need to be
recycled along with plastic and glass
bottles and metals that make up half of
the 292 million tons of waste we produce
every year
that mountain of waste material we all
generate has prompted new ways to think
about how we recycle and who pays for it
brook silva braga sorts through this
messy issue
it's recycling day in long beach new
york and when the town's public works
commissioner joseph fabrizio sees
bottles and cans he's thinking about
dollars and cents i overheard you a
second ago saying there was a time when
you made money on recycling yes it was
probably like 2015 when you used to
actually make money
even when that changed and recycling
cost a couple dollars a ton it was
really minimal we were spending about
six thousand dollars a year that was
still a very good deal because this is
all stuff the town didn't have to pay
much bigger money to put in a landfill
but then this year their long-running
recycling contract expired now we're
paying eighty dollars a ton wait eighty
dollars a ton eighty dollars a ton it
was two dollars it was two twenty five
correct that was eighty dollars now it's
eighty dollars that old six thousand
dollar annual bill will be more like a
hundred thousand this year and that
shock happened all across the country
for a fairly simple reason in 2018 china
stopped buying our recycling they've
been embarrassed by the film plastic
china portraying them as the world's
dumping ground and anyway it would be
easier for china to recycle their own
stuff if they didn't have higher quality
american materials to compete with all
of a sudden the biggest market said they
were going to stop taking it so prices
crashed and all of these recycling
programs started losing
lots and lots of money adam minter has
been writing about recycling for 20
years and he says environmental concerns
may be how we motivate households to
separate their trash but they've never
been enough to make recycling work as an
industry the best way to think about
recycling is it's raw materials for
manufacturing if nobody wants to use it
that stuff you put in your recycling bin
is as good as garbage and as prices fell
that did happen these glass bottles here
they're just going to end up in the
trash they probably will and some in
government started looking at recycling
differently if all this packaging is
going to cost us money rather than save
it maybe we should take a harder look at
the whole system those who put the
packaging out into the world bear no
responsibility for the cost of recycling
their own product todd kaminsky is a
democratic state senator in new york
pushing legislation to push the cost of
recycling onto the companies creating
the packaging it's called epr or
extended producer responsibility the
idea isn't just to make companies like
amazon pay for all the packaging they
pour onto our doorsteps but also
incentivize companies to make packages
that will be easier to recycle we want
them to pay more for the more damaging
their product is and less for the better
their product is at the end of the day
they're going to be kicking money into
the system to help municipalities do
recycling and do it well won't they just
pass the cost onto consumers what we
found in other places is that the cost
is so informative it's barely registers
to consumers those other places already
using epr include parts of canada in
europe the new law shifts some of the
recycling burden onto large corporations
maine and oregon passed america's first
epr laws this summer but they aren't in
effect yet some big companies including
pepsi and unilever have voiced support
for epr perhaps because big producers
will decide how fees are set
smaller businesses like grocery store
chains have been vocal opponents
amazon didn't respond to our request for
comment about epr a commitment to using
less materials but they've previously
boasted about cutting the weight of
their packaging by more than a third
and now offer the option to receive
orders in fewer boxes
amazon says they're doing a lot to make
their packaging more efficient you
disagree
i just don't think in a epr system we
leave it up to them to decide what they
want to do and maybe they will or maybe
they won't but either way why should
amazon not bear the cost of having so
many more garbage pickups so many more
recycling pickups that municipalities
can't handle
stand above new york city's recycling
heap and the scale of our waste can be
hard to fathom our trucks collect from
residences across new york city and it's
all delivered right here and this is a
month's worth the weeks were less than
half a day's worth
it's kind of staggering it is yes
much of it does have value again the
recent supply chain crisis has driven
back up the price of these raw materials
at least for the companies processing
them at least for now
but adam minter says we shouldn't let
commodity prices or a debate over who
pays the tab
confuse us about the full cost of what
we buy and discard i think a lot of
environmentalists think you know you put
something in your recycling bin and it
goes off to green heaven but you know
recycling is a raw material business it
requires factories it requires energy
inputs it can be dirty if people are
really concerned about the environmental
impact of using materials they should
reduce their consumption altogether
something for us all to process as we
fill our carts this month
for cbs saturday morning brooksville the
wreck
new york
makes sense yeah and that's just
recycling right you imagine the other
trash out there how much in volume we
consume and i think you know bringing it
out of the dark
where we see this trash and recycling
headed
is going to lighten the load eventually
one of the big things there is what
brooks mentioned there at the end which
is the issue of you put things in the
recycling bin and you think what you
just wash your hands it's off to green
heaven it's it's not necessarily that
simple yeah knowing where that trash
goes knowing where that recycling goes
and knowing how it has to be put in
there so that it can be recycled as well
good piece brook thank you very much
there